tenemos que tres más un espacio es igual
a 10 así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
descifrar qué valor debe de llenar ese
espacio que le debemos sumar a 3 para
llegar a 10
suponiendo que ya lo has intentado ahora
veamos si podemos hacer esto juntos por
aquí tengo tres de estos creo que
podemos decirte estos círculos morado
rosa y tengo 10 cajas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
y 10 una manera de pensar en esto es
cuántos círculos más tengo que añadir
para llenar todas las cajas
bueno contemos eso juntos
necesito sumar 1 2
5 6 y 7 para llenar las 10 cajas por
completo así que tres más que valor es
igual a diez tres más uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete es igual a diez
hagamos uno más de estos ahora tengo
más un espacio es igual a 10 así que
nuevamente pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes descubrir qué valor debe ir en el
espacio qué valor debes de añadir a 6
para llegar a 10 hagámoslo juntos
ahora tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 círculos
tenemos diez cajas aquí
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 y sólo debemos
pensar cuántos círculos más necesitamos
para llenar todas las cajas para llegar
a 10 ya tenemos 6 llenas necesitamos 1 2
4 para llegar a 10 así que sólo tenemos
eso 6 + 4 es igual a 10 o podemos
incluso decir que 46 es igual a 10
cualquiera de las dos formas